have you ever felt Oh annoyed in the
world
[Music]
yeah that feeling you just got from
watching those videos that's called
being annoyed hello before I even say
anything I want to say Happy 500
subscribers is that right let me see oh
well tag literally my last upload was my
thank you for 200 subscribers and now I
have to say thank you for 1,200
subscribers plus you guys are awesome
thank you to everybody who's watching my
videos new and old subscriber and not
for sticking around and really growing
this channel over the past couple days
weeks literally but enough of that now
it's time for the actual intro
[Music]
hello my friends on the internet mask
and hit abandon hearing today I'm going
to deviate from doing Zelda theories I
know I know you all love my theories so
much well don't you fret because there
are more coming but today we're going to
be talking about something different
we're going to be talking about annoying
people in Zelda games specifically my
list of the top 10 annoying side
characters and Zelda games across all
the zone games I played I want to jump
right into the content but I feel like I
have to set a couple ground rules first
so here we go first up an attempt to not
pull most or even all of my annoying
picks from the same Zelda game I'm
purposefully cutting the selection short
from getting to gain meaning my list
definitely doesn't include all of the
annoying characters in any specific
Zelda game just the most annoying ones
second even though a character may make
the list that does not mean that I
dislike the character personally I mean
no hard feelings am i right hey if you
grew up with siblings you know what I'm
talking about
even though our siblings annoyed the
crap out of us growing up we still love
them right right they asked you to say
that you're fine you're not really
thirdly lastly and finally I want to say
something else
there is no enjoy the list first up we
have the one-and-only Ravalli from
breath of the wild you know how everyone
has that one friend that just seems like
they're not really a friend but they
kind of hang out with who you hang out
with and you tolerate their presence and
stuff well imagine that friend and also
they hate you
that's Ravalli - link be it out of
jealousy or just plain disdain Ravalli
spends the majority of the scenes he
shows up in bashing link for not being
as heroic as he is or as good with a bow
and arrow as he is or even for not being
able to fly as well as he does which is
probably because link doesn't have wings
in addition to his blatant jealousy of
our beloved boy who does not talk he's
also notoriously prideful and is known
for his I'm better than you attitude to
everyone he talks to I mean even when
he's about to compliment you at the end
of middle questline he's all
I guess I was wrong about how lucky I
would be like really man would it kill
you to say you were wrong about how
awesome Linc is or maybe you were wrong
about how much of a jerk you are or you
were just wrong
dot-dot-dot implying without completely
verifying the fact that you know you
undercut the legendary hero resurrected
in the flesh before your very eyes nope
he's just gonna be salty even after
death yeah Ravalli takes our pick at
annoying side character number 10 for
annoying person number 9 we're gonna go
somewhere far away somewhere lost and
woodsy meat or remate might oh the
doubtful Co curry this lost soul may be
a blessed child of the dica tree but
he's no saint he serves as the first
little mini antagonists to link at the
very start of ocarina of time so there
you are
eyes wide with Wonder at this Nature
playground you so happened to live in
with children who are eternally children
playing eternal games of hide-and-seek
this fairy comes up to you and mutters
something about being summoned by some
tree and boom in your way blocking you
is my toe he says some stuff about you
not even being a real man which I mean
is true cuz you're kind of sort of still
a little boy and he even makes another
ko Curry kid cut grass that he said he
would cut so that's Surya or I would
like him what a jerk and yeah I know he
was necessary to the game so that link
would have to equip a sword and shield
before taking on real enemies yeah yeah
yeah he's still a big Meany head he
would probably play some mean deep ends
in a game of basketball though
next up is Zil I don't think I need that
much of a reason just Zill zillion has
some aspects should I say of himself
that have proven - how should I say give
me nightmares
number seven brings us back to good ol
ocarina of time specifically in the
Zoro's domain there comes a time when
you have to physically move the king
zora so that you can walk to the other
side of his enormous body and when you
ask him to move he oh just watch this
[Music]
[Music]
ah Illya sweet sweet Illya how annoying
you are yes that's right number six is
Illya from Twilight Princess oh why you
ask well how about just a couple you
know or a few different points here real
quick let's see
she's the entitled mayor's daughter she
overly scolds link and her own dad she
thinks she can take care of the pony
better than Lincoln she develops a
complete loss of memory that just so
happens to excuse her jerkish behavior
from before she somehow even more
annoying when she loses her memory and
she's shown in this space he cutscene
trying to kill link with a knife I guess
she did make this really cool little
flute thing for link to call Epona with
whenever he wants to but it's not like
you don't have to go find it yourself
and bring it to her for her just sayyin
gave it annoying now here's the game I
don't talk about enough Skyward Sword in
the game Skyward Sword link is
constantly one second away from catching
up with Zelda who was revealed pretty
quickly after she's lost to be being led
somewhere by a large mysterious woman
named Impa meet number five impo
literally tells ling she can protect his
l-dub better than Lincoln she says
meanie PI stuff like link it took you
too long oh I think the goddess chose
you wrongly I bad and can never defend
Zelda she also acts like she can protect
the Triforce Zelda and the fate of the
world by holding back demise alone even
though she isn't and knows she isn't the
chosen of the goddess to do so talk
about entitlement I mean for a character
who is later revealed to be some really
smart old lady who's totally travelled
through time and should have a fantastic
grasp on the matters at hand she's kind
of wrong about all of it number four is
honestly a really fun character from
breadth of the wild that unfortunately
makes this list because the dialogue
options are so long and tedious meet
bolson founder of pulsing construction
whose employees are only people whose
names end in son sorry link better
Lahontan like I said I honestly really
liked bolson and his whole
Jona the part I don't like however is
the fact that you have to talk to him
and get through all his same dialogue
selections every single time you want to
add something to your house it sucks and
takes forever it's annoying
but at least he does seem like an
amazing invite to a wedding am i right
maybe don't you love babies I mean the
really loud crying ones the ones that
don't shut up like the quran elder son
from majora's mask coming in at annoying
character number three I can't even with
this kid he just won't shop he cries so
loud that he extinguishes the flame on
his torches he cries forever until you
figure out his low by and play it for
him which for some people especially if
you're anything like me might take you a
while to find just listen to this crap
[Music]
[Music]
number two is a real pervy character
hailing from breath of the wild beause I
the 35 year old nobody who has nothing
better to do than jog all day on the hot
sands outside of the conveniently
all-women Gerudo city takes the cake in
the first place he only likes link at
that point based off of links looks
meaning he's basically a 35 year old
horn dog and he calls you a hungry
little boot monster Oh also after you do
this quest to find a huge lady statue
take a picture of it and bring it back
he doesn't give you the boots you were
just using you have to then do another
picture quest to get the original boots
back it's just tedious and annoying and
I'm sure rather scarring for poor link
man poor guys last but certainly not
least we have the one and only owl that
has ever been known to talk more than he
listens que porra Gabe Ora himself this
owl greets young link the first time as
he's leaving the Kokiri Forest and
proceeds to not only creepy the hack out
if you're a kid watching this twisting
owls head spin completely upside down
but also spew way too much knowledge out
and just to make matters worse punishes
you if you're spamming the a button
repeatedly to skip through his dialogue
by switching the yes and no buttons when
he asks if you want to hear it all again
the little devil eventually you may get
out of the loop but Shh
this moment here with the owl is to me
way more annoying than a certain other
flying friend of ours and with that
we've reached the end of the list what
did you think did I miss anyone comment
below and let me know what your most
annoying side character is across the
Zelda universe also be sure to leave me
a like and subscribe with that Bell for
much more gaming content to come check
out some of my other videos and theories
if you want to stay non annoying my
internet friends but don't worry I'll
still love you if they are thanks for
watching and have a great rest of your
day
peace
[Music]